hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of Melina masters I
believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow your business is
to model the strategies that people who
have already done what you're trying to
do so today we're going to look at the
story of how a 38 year old man who had
never written an advertisement in his
life started an ad agency with $6,000 to
his name and went on to become one of
the most sought-after marketers in the
world this is a story of advertising
legend David Ogilvy and the top three
lessons that you can learn from his
success David Ogilvy was a founder of Oh
Govinda Mader and is known as the father
of advertising
he took the long road to success working
as a hotel chef a British intelligence
officer and a traveling salesman selling
kitchen stoves door-to-door he had
success in sales and thought he could
help other companies improve their
marketing efforts so he started his own
advertising agency in 1949 he was 38
years old had never written an
advertisement in his life and only had
$6,000 to his name but he had a big
dream and wanted to see it through
attracting clients was a challenge in
the beginning but he focused on getting
results for his clients and he firmly
believed that the best way to get new
clients was to do outstanding work for
his existing clients the few clients who
was able to get loved his approach they
rewarded him with larger budgets and
referrals to other potential accounts
after building up his business in New
York he decided to merge with the
london-based
agency mayor and Crowther in 1965 it
gave his firm in international reach and
the next year olga van Mather was one of
the first advertising agencies to go
public his company was acquired in 1989
for 864 million dollars after Ogilvy
built up reputation for being the most
sought-after wizard in the advertising
industry according to Time magazine he
was elected to the US advertising Hall
of Fame in 1977 and was inducted into
the Junior Achievement US business Hall
of Fame his legacy continues to leave a
mark on everyone in the advertising
world and his story provides lessons in
marketing that we can
learn from by focusing on his clients
and by building his referrals David
Ogilvy was able to go from a startup
with zero experience into the most
recognized person in his industry to
help you boost your client referrals
here are three action items that you can
learn from David Ogilvy action item
number one get your clients results do
you want more referrals for your
business blow your current clients away
with how great a job you do don't just
exceed expectations go way above and
beyond your customers are busy people if
you want them to talk about you then you
need to give them a reason to referred
clients spend more buy more often have a
shorter sales cycle and are way easier
to work with referrals are the best way
to attract more ideal clients so start
offering so much extra value into what
you do that they can't help but talk to
everyone they know about you Olga V maid
getting results for his clients his
firms top priority he realized that if
he didn't deliver they wouldn't get
repeat business or client referrals he
didn't want ads that were too creative
that people couldn't understand he also
didn't want well-written ads that were
boring and weren't going to be read he
focused instead on creating ads that
were bringing in dollars for his clients
which is what he believed he was hired
to do for his clients when he believed
too many awards are being handed out in
his industry for creativity he created
his own David Ogilvy award to recognize
a campaign that did the most to improve
a client's sales or reputation the award
look everybody at his company know that
they should focus primarily on making a
cash register ring and not being the
most creative according Olga V in the
modern world of business it is useless
to be a creative original thinker unless
you can also sell what you create we
sell or else the recommendations we make
should be the recommendations we would
make if we own their companies without
regard to our own short-term interests
this earns their respect which is the
greatest asset we can have we exist to
build the businesses of our clients
action item number two test test test
what you start off with is never what
you end up with your products and
services change your marketing changes
and your business plan changes the only
way to figure out if something is going
to work or not
is to test don't wait until you have the
perfect idea or perfect business plan
because they don't exist start sooner
get feedback from potential customers
and make changes and continue to test
test test until you start getting the
results that you're looking for Olga V
like to create campaigns that had a big
idea attached to them if you don't
promote your business with a big idea
then people were largely ignore you he
realized that in order for your big idea
to work you have to test Olga we
believed in the importance of research
so much that when you open this company
his official title was research director
he tested everything about his campaigns
until he honed in on the concepts that
delivered the best results according to
Olga V you aren't advertising to a
standing army you're advertising too
moving parade the most important word in
the vocabulary of advertising is test
test your promise test your media test
your headlines in your illustrations
test the size of your advertisements
test your frequency test your level of
expenditure test your commercials never
stop testing and your advertising will
never stop improving if you pre test
your product with consumers and pre test
your advertising you will do well in the
marketplace action item number three
hire great people read almost any famous
entrepreneur profile and you'll see the
hiring great people was one of the core
strategies that helped propel their
success you need to figure out what
you're really good at and where you add
the most value to your business then
hire amazing people to do everything
else hire people who believe in what
you're doing and who love doing the
tasks you need them to do so you can
focus on building your business Olga V
understood how important it is to have a
great team of people working with you he
therefore spent a great deal of effort
making sure that they were given
challenging opportunities recognition
for achievement and as much
responsibility as they could handle he
invested in the hiring training and gave
them independence and flexibility
if an employee was battling a personal
problem like illness or alcohol abuse
the company would make every effort to
help them in return however Ogilvy
demanded the most famous people and had
exceedingly high expectations of them
according to Olga V if we hire people
who are smaller than we are we become a
company of Dwarfs if we hire people who
are larger than we are we become a
company of giants some of our people
spend their entire working lives in
Ogilvy & Mather
we try to make it a stimulating and
happy experience we put this first we
see no conflict between adherence to
high professional standards in our work
and human kindness in our dealings with
each other we treat our people as human
beings I believe in a Scottish proverb
hard work never killed a man men die of
boredom psychological conflict and
disease they do not die of hard work set
exorbitant standards and give your
people hell when they don't live up to
them there is nothing so demoralizing as
a boss who tolerates second-rate work
so remember get your clients results
test test test and hire great people to
finish up this video I wanted to share
one of my favorite true stories well
David Ogilvy and some of his best quotes
in his ads Ogilvy would often make the
company logo twice the size a good thing
to do because most advertisements are
deficient in brand identification he
would also show his clients faces
because the public is more interested in
personalities than in corporations
author Ogilvy techniques include
studying and imitating graphics used by
editors since it's been found that the
lasting advertisement looks like an
advertisement and the more it looks like
an editorial the more readers stop look
and read he would place photographs at
the top of his ads given that people
have a habit of scanning down words and
also learned that there's very little
value in saying something without
illustrating it because the viewer
immediately forgets it
thank you for joining me for another
edition of my Linda masters if you like
the video and want to see more please
give it a thumbs up below I'd also love
to hear feedback if you want to leave a
comment under the video and stay tuned
for next episode
you